hey everyone thanks for coming to my
talk today my name is adriel and and I'm
gonna talk a little bit today about an
R&D project that I've been involved with
in charge of that work and it's it's
dealt a lot with you know building an
application in a CDF and I'm going to
talk about some of the lessons that I've
learned working on that project just a
brief outline I'm gonna talk a little
bit about my company and what we do and
I think that that's sort of helpful to
frame the discussion and what I'm gonna
what's going to follow that I'm going to
talk a little bit about technology in
the oil and gas industry and then I'm
going to formally introduce our Rd
project called
Alex and then I'm going to talk through
some of the the things that I've learned
with application development and the
Wolfram language and then finally I'll
just have a couple quick remarks about
Wolfram language versus traditional
languages and things like that so about
me my background is in chemical
engineering and and I only say that to
sort of preface the rest of this
presentation I'm sure there's a lot of
people out in the audience right now
that are you know probably a lot better
than me at some of this stuff and and
but really my goal here is just to say
you know some of the things that I've
learned over the last year and a half
working on this and I think some of them
are really good and they'll be really
useful for a lot of people out there
I've got five years of experience and
working in oil and gas now and I'm a my
around my first year halfway through my
first year I got introduced to
Mathematica by a colleague and and I
really challenged myself I could see
right away the the value then what you
could do with it and I challenged myself
to basically learn as much as I possibly
could about it and the way I did that is
is I just I forced myself not to open up
Excel and open up all those other things
and I made myself do everything with
Mathematica and it was you know a little
bit of a learning curve at first but
it's really paid off a lot now I use it
I use it for everything so just quick
company overview my company assured flow
solutions we focus on specialty
engineering and consulting in the
upstream oil and gas section the
specialty that we fall under is what's
called flow assurance and basically what
flow assurance is is we attempt to
sure that you have flow of hydrocarbons
from your reservoir to your topsides
most of our work is off so our offshore
so we're dealing a lot with subsea
pipelines primarily and and there's a
you know there's a lot of issues that
you can run into that people wouldn't
really think about a lot of those are
just pure sort of hydraulics you know
how do you how do you produce from a
well that's 20,000 feet below the ocean
in 8,000 feet of water do you have the
reservoir pressure that you need to
produce that kind of well there's a lot
of issues we deal with that have to do
with two phase and three phase flow so
sometimes when you're when you're
producing from a reservoir you've got
you've got water you've got oil you've
got gas and it's all flowing in the same
pipeline and that creates a lot of
operational issues that people weren't
really aware of some of the other things
that we focus on are some production
chemistry type issues related directly
to the oil so this is a picture of
what's called a hydrate and hydrated it
looks very similar to ice and it sort of
is in some ways but it's basically it
can form when you've got methane and
water present in your pipeline the real
the real special thing about it is that
it forms under high pressures and low
temperatures which is the exact
environment that you have in an offshore
pipeline just for for reference some of
the the ocean bed floor in the Gulf of
Mexico is around 36 to 40 degrees
Fahrenheit so it's really really cold
down there it's above freezing but it's
really cold and the hydrates they can
form the special thing about them is
that they form above freezing
temperatures you know they're very
pressure dependent so if one of these
forms and it blocks your pipeline then
you've got a major problem not only a
safety concern but you've also got loss
of production which is million-dollar
millions dollars per day so this is a
this is an example of a of an oil that's
got a lot of paraffin content in it and
that paraffin when it's exposed to a
cold pipeline it can it can deposit on
the inner inner wall of the pipe and
over time as it builds up it can cause a
lot of issues you can see it almost to
the point where it's blocking the
pipeline right there and then this is
asphaltenes which can are another
characteristic of oils and sometimes
they can precipitate out under the right
conditions and when they do they just
form there's no way to dissolve them or
anything like that they just they form
and they can it can accumulate and block
your pipeline so we got we've got four
locations two in Houston wanted down
someone in Denver and we're sort of
really spread out we only have 20 people
in the company so for four locations
it's pretty stress really thin we just
opened up a new production chemistry lab
it opened last January and and the focus
there was we've primarily done
engineering it's holding work before
with the production chemistry lab we
were able to do some of the fluid
testing that we need to do on these oil
samples ourselves and basically be a
third-party verification for some of
that stuff I made a couple slightly with
the engineering work when you've got
models that you're running simulations
they they require parameters that you
get from running these kinds of analysis
on the fluid samples themselves so so a
couple very tightly with with it and it
was sort of something we were aiming to
you know increase as far as coupling
even more in the future so okay so in
technology in oil gas it really comes
down to one thing and that's better
drilling when you're talking about
spending tens of millions it's not 100
million dollars to drill well especially
offshore anything that you can do to
increase that process make it more
efficient it's gonna is gonna equate to
a lot of money so the downside of that
is that we're generally late to the game
as far as you know conventional
technology things related to computers
and you know and those types of things
and and so the real thing I want to
point out is that Excel is still very
dominant everyone uses Excel if you get
something from from clients it's it's
Excel and if you send something it's
Excel technology at my company so we're
we're we use a lot of very expensive
simulation software to sort of run our
models and that's sort of the base of it
but we're no different from anyone else
in the industry a lot of our stuff used
to be Excel it used to be you know
one-off executables and you know it was
just sort of scattered everywhere like I
said I personally used the Wolfram
language for 80% of my work and I've
been trying to get that to December to
know that number to grow you know spread
awareness and what my colleagues and
things like that but really about a year
and a half ago we realized that we
needed something better when you did
some way that we could manage all these
internal processes that we have and
workflows and calculations and so we
decided to make something
that would they would handle that so so
like I said we needed something you know
that would handle these these
spreadsheets you know one-off
executables and even just you know VBA
macros and then we've got even just
company knowledge there's there's things
that there's people to have a lot of
experience and there's things that are
in their head and unless you go and talk
to them there's no way to get it out and
so we wanted to try to capture that as
well in this so before we started we had
this naming challenge for this Rd tool
that we wanted to build and the winner
was someone who submitted the name Alex
and it was named after the Library of
Alexandria which was the largest and
most significant library the ancient
world and it was only about two weeks
after that someone pointed out that that
library actually burned down so we're
hoping not to have the same fate with
our Alex so just really quick let me
kind of formally and show you Alex
it's it's developed in Mathematica by me
and it's distributed to my colleagues
via an enterprise CDF currently we'd
have 37 unique utilities in it and those
are sort of a combination of
calculations work gloves
you know processes all types of things
basically we just wanted a one-stop shop
for anything R&D related that we had I
can open it really quickly like I said
it runs in a CDF and over on this side
we've kind of got your main utility
panel and each one of these are unique
over here on the left is is where you've
got a list of all the available
utilities and you can do some nice
searching features if you need to search
for a particular thing and it will sort
of filter the list so that's that's sort
of what it looks like here's that here's
a better way to sort of look at some of
the unique utilities that are available
in it and these are just some of them
not all of them just to give you a quick
highlight
so so like I said it leverages the power
of the enterprise CDF and that allows us
to have arbitrary input fields and we
can import file types of any of any type
which is really nice the searchable
field is also really nice you know
there's lots of times where you're not
quite sure what utility you need for the
job and if you put in a few keywords
I've tried to make it so that it's easy
to find that I've also added support for
250 oil and gas units that we have I
know there's unit conversion built in in
the Wolfram language but I wanted
something that that didn't require an
internet connection and something that
we could easily build into the
functional programming so that's that's
kind of what you know these will these
will look like just one really basic
example and the thing that's nice about
how it's built is that I can run this in
Mathematica and I don't have to you know
run it in a CDF the way that my my
colleagues do so this is a really simple
utility but we use it quite often to
generate a hydrate curve which of those
those things I mentioned earlier and
this basically shows us you know as far
as what is your temperature and your
pipeline and what's your pressure and if
you're to the left of this curve you're
at a you're at a pretty big risk for
forming hydrate in your line and
blocking it and if you're to the right
you're sort of okay and we can add you
know inhibitor which they'll inject a
lot of chemicals into the pipeline to
help avoid some of these these
operational issues and and you can see
the effect of adding methanol basically
shifts that curve to the left and so you
you now have a whole you can go a lot
lower in your temperature and still not
have as many you still not have that
operational risk this is a little bit
more exam ants example some of the
pipelines that we look at are really
highly engineered pipelines you know
it's not it's not a simple steel pipe
that they're just laying on the ground
there's there's a lot of engineering
that goes into the insulation of them
when you're dealing with temperatures
that are you know a few degrees above
freezing you need to have as much
insulation as you can and so there's a
lot of different wall layers in some of
these pipes and so we built this utility
and he uses nd solve and we can specify
the wall materials you know the thermal
properties of it and then if we
calculate it we can basically simulate
as soon as I shut in a pipeline you know
how long do I have and a cool down time
until I hit some designated temperature
and that's going to be the temperature
which you know I'm not
for for some operational issues normally
hydrates but the nice thing is because
it's you know it's an interpolating
function I can also look at these
results not just in the time domain but
I can also look at I can look at Matt in
the spatial domain and sort of the
radial distance in the pipeline so how
do we decide to develop Alex we had a
couple options we had Excel
visual studio we had Mathematica and you
know I'm obviously a huge supporter of
Mathematica but at the end of the day
what it really came down to was that we
needed something that we could belt very
fast like we're not we're not in the R&D
business we're in the you know clients
and project business and something so we
needed needed something that worked it
was accurate and and we could build it
really quickly and so and develop 37
different utilities inside of visual
basis is not something that's gonna take
the amount of time that we needed it to
or though it doesn't mount of time that
we had so so the code structure is so
that the rest of the slides that I just
want to go through really kind of
briefly on each one how you know I've
approached a certain issue related to
application development with the Wolfram
language and and just to give you guys
an idea of how it's all set up so alex
is contained in a package that's really
nice for naming conventions it makes it
really easy to isolate your code and
using the different you know the colon
key or whatever you can isolate it and
grab a particular variable from a
certain context I also like the package
editor basically just because it allows
me to collapse these different sections
and I can organize it really nicely I
can I can have you know an image
individual module and then everything
related to that and and isolate out the
methods from the UI and things like that
and the other thing that's nice is when
you have it in a package as opposed to
see yet you can protect that and you can
encode it and and that way your
intellectual property is safe so the
insights into the UI really quick the
whole so the whole thing is obviously in
the CDF on the top we've got a docked
cell and then the remainder of the the
notebook runs is all wrapped around a
dynamic module wrapped inside of a
dynamic module and then each individual
utility
has its own dynamic module and then
inside of that is a pain because a lot
of these extend beyond on the screen and
we wanted something that we could scroll
through and then over here that
searchable field that I mentioned before
and then just a pane here with a with a
column of buttons in each one if you
click it it you know it sets the the
appropriate utility that you want to
view so all of us have written
Mathematica code we know that there's no
compiling and that's that's what's great
about it I did want to have something
that would allow me to build Aleks and
what it basically does is I brought this
function that compiles to Kyle Aleks and
it and it takes the file as a package
and it moves it over to the appropriate
user base directory for Mathematica and
for C or for the CDF player and then in
the process it encodes it so that it's
it's protected and you can't can't view
it in Roth text form and what it also
will do is update a version number that
that I can maintain separate from the
utility and then if I want I can it has
an option that it will accept its own
version number so if I want to increment
the next version number I can do that
manually
so version control it's you know it's
critical for any successful software
project and in Alex because it's in a
package form and it's a text form it's
very easy to maintain it using it and
because it's raw text you can do discs
on the different versions really easily
so it's it's nice as opposed to using a
notebook which has a lot of cells and a
different a lot of additional text if
you actually look inside of it and and
that makes it a little bit more
difficult for the version control
updates when I first started working on
our we was updates sometimes twice a
week and I always wanted to make sure
that people had an easy way to get the
latest version so I have all the files
sort of associated with Alex in one
central spot and then I wrote this
little executable here and that'll copy
those files to the the appropriate spot
on their computer system under there
under that same user user base directory
and that way when the when the Alex
launches it knows exactly where to go to
look for those for those files and it
can load them in really easily
so this is something I I've only
recently started doing actually and I
knew that Wolfram had automated testing
but I hadn't had a chance to really look
at it yet and and once I did I was I was
really impressed I mean just just like
anything else with real form it's it's
really easy to test your functions and
you can write you know a few few lines
to change some variables and account for
different things that the user might do
and then you can run a test and set that
up as a test and then when you run it
you'll easily see if you if you broken
anything with the past version stuff
like that which which I tend to do so
it's nice to have this bug reporting so
right away when I first built this I
built in the upper right corner of this
little button report bug and it uses the
the send mail function to basically send
me send me a email and with that email
I'll get information about all the
variables and that utility what current
utility they're using and it also sent
me you can take a front-end screen shot
using Mathematica code and it'll send me
a screenshot of that and lots of times I
can see you know what are the red boxes
or something you know something's not
working right but you really need some
some way to do that because Wolfram's
really good about not letting their
program crash so you don't necessarily
know that it just it just broke you just
know that something's not really working
right and so I needed some way to report
that and let people know and and now I
probably get one of these every every
two to three weeks so so there's been
improvement debugging I know there are
ways of debugging inside of the package
inside of the notebook interface and
other other areas but I tend to just do
it directly in Mathematica I like to be
able to do exactly whatever my colleague
that broke something whatever they were
doing I like to repeat those steps in
here and then I'll generally just look
at you know the exact variables and and
I can look at you know just the raw data
and things like that I can kind of
figure out what's going on like that
it's that's how I'll generally approach
it just a couple extras one of the big
things that we wanted was an easy way to
get data out of the utility so we used
to when I originally wrote this we had
an export function and what it would do
is let someone save the file somewhere
and then Excel file a CSV file and you
kind of file and then you know it
export that data and then when they
needed that they would have to go open
that data and I was always really
interested in the idea of the copy to
clipboard but if you've ever used it in
Mathematica and you and you actually
copied the data it's really nice for
pasting in between notebooks but it's
not really nice if you want to paste it
to Excel so so I wrote my own my own
data and and then when I paste that it
looks a little weird right here but if
you were to paste that in Excel to be
tab-separated and and everything would
look really nice so that's that's built
into all the utilities and you can just
export all that data really easily and
you don't have to do that that second
and third step the save load every every
utility that's in there right now has
has an option to save the current
configuration and I wanted something
that was really generic to do that and
so I basically wrote this this little
code right here and it'll take the name
whatever the utility is and then all my
variables associated with that it'll
write them as an association to a file
with the string as the variable and then
the value and then similarly when I load
that back in I can take those those same
strings and just convert them into into
symbols and then set the values and and
it works really nicely and I don't ever
have to manually go through and set
which variables I want to say it just
it's handled for each utility okay
finally
so advantages of Wolfram language for
application development algorithms can
be developed very quickly and you
generally require a lot less code which
which I'm sure all of you are aware of
but when it comes to things like R&D
projects it's really nice to have and
its really nice to do it that way
limitations for me as far as what I saw
with application development there were
some strong limitations and the UI
capabilities I don't think you're ever
going to be able to develop a
professional you know looking desktop
application you know there's just some
limits in the in the way the notebook is
set up but I mean I think you can get to
something that looks pretty nice and and
especially if it's for quick you know
internal development I think it'll
probably meet any requirements that you
have
so conclusion so future Daleks we've got
a growing list of utilities to add right
now probably you know we're at 37 I
think I'll probably easily get up to 50
we're dealing a lot more with the lab
now with our lab and sort of coupling
the engineering work with the lab and
there's there's a lot of opportunities
there to expand further with that and
I've been really interested in the the
cloud opportunities and learning
specifically about API functions is way
to to call those instead of running
these things through CDF so that all
that might be in the future
so Wolfram language obviously plays a
very vital role at a fast not just for
me I use it personally and every sort of
work function I do but also in the
ability to distribute these the CDF to
my colleagues which get used daily as
well and lastly you know I think we're
all aware that Wolfram language can play
a huge role in the industry and sort of
preaching to the choir obviously but you
know I think it's all of our jobs to you
know just increase that awareness and
you know keep doing what we're doing
spreading the word because it's a really
powerful tool and that's it thank you
[Applause]